everybody is Charlie this is going to be
my guardians of the galaxy to Easter
eggs
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet there's a new round of the
Guardians giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so there were a bunch of
Easter eggs starting with a big one the
old Mattel football game when I saw this
in the trailer I thought that he had
modified it to help detect the alien
that was coming through the Apple esc'
but turns out he just playing a video
game the sovereign themselves Alysha big
Easter eggs for Adam warlock stuff that
happened in the comics they were sort of
a stand-in for the Enclave which is a
group of humans that genetically
engineered all these people the way they
explained it in the movie is that the
sovereign did this to themselves and
they are bringing about the creation of
Adam warlock but Aisha also known as
kismet in the comics came after Adam
warlock in the first time she came out
of a cocoon she was actually a man she
was intended to be another space Jesus
but then she rebelled and went back into
a cocoon came out looking like a woman
looking for a mate ended up getting
married to quasar and gave birth to star
hawk who of course was played by
Sylvester Stallone in a big roundup of
the original guardians 3000 team so
unless you've read a lot of really old
comics the guardians of the galaxy that
you know are the more recent iteration
of the team they came together during
the annihilation conquest storyline
which was a big Ultron in space
storyline that team was the big
post-credit scene that everyone was
talking about so that was the team that
yeondu was a part of the very first one
in the comics it was marked annex
which was actually played by Michael
Rosenbaum you couldn't tell because he
looked all crystalline Charlie 27 yondu
himself with the giant bin Starhawk
Alita or gourd star Hawks wife which is
played by Michelle yeah a lot of people
were like why is the woman from thor
ragnarok in this no that's not her
that's Michelle yow Miley Cyrus was
probably the biggest surprise she's the
voice of mainframe I missed you guys so
much and then Kruger who's actually got
these magical powers that look just like
dr. strange that's a huge easter egg so
obviously they borrowed those special
effects copy/paste straight out of the
Doctor Strange movie so that's kind of
what magic looks like in the Marvel
Universe right now in way back in the
comics dr. strange found him in the 22nd
century took him as an apprentice and
talked Krueger
to work magic so who knows how they'll
explain that but apparently he trained
from a previous version of the ancient
one
the newer guardians team had Cosmo on it
he wasn't a big part of the movie but he
did show up during the post-credits
scene as did the grand master from thor
ragnarok he was a weird addition because
there was no legit thor ragnarok
post-credit scene but I think it was
just a way to remind people that that's
the next movie that's coming up he's a
really big character from the comics a
big part of the infinity war arc so it's
going to be nuts but then obviously a
leisure Hatch's Adam warlock in a cocoon
at the end of the movie presumably he'll
come out of that at the beginning of the
third guardians film which is
tentatively dated for 2020 right after
the fourth Avengers film that sort of
been bookmark James Gunn said three more
years so that puts it at 2020 they could
always change that date though but there
is a Guardians 3 it is on the schedule
now when the sovereign started attacking
the Guardians it just can't gave you an
idea that they were going to be used for
comedy because all of their ships made
video game arcade sounds in the whole
mechanism of them piloting the ships was
very Galaga he was almost like their
command center was a giant video game
arcade it was one of the funniest jokes
in the movie there is a lot of video
game laid across this movie in different
ways they go into that asteroid field
James Gunn himself is a huge fan of
video games grew up being crazy about
them so that's one of the reasons why he
infused a lot of those elements into the
movie in visual ways in narrative ways
so things sound like video games in some
of the big action set-pieces even seem
like a pinball game like when they're
jumping through those 700 jumps to get
to egos planet the planet burn hurt that
they crash on is actually straight out
of The Incredible Hulk comics it shows
up during issue number 111 is this big
space adventure so obviously we're going
to be seeing the Hulk again very soon
still need to find out how he gets there
but the shirt that star-lords wearing is
actually a space candy brand that James
Gunn made for guardians of the galaxy
but the costume designer use the fake
space language for these characters that
they used in the first film it just says
gears shift in that fake language but
it's kind of like wearing a Snickers or
a skittles t-shirt the ravager planet
contracts SIA is really crazy in the
movie but in the comics it's just the
home of the mother of Jack of Hearts
this is like a normal planet is not
nearly as cool as the version that James
Gunn did Tommy Flanagan's character took
is actually straight out of that
annihilation conquest storyline where
the original Guardians got together
except in that story he was working for
Ronan the accuser then we see Howard the
Duck pop back up they did say that
Howard the Duck would pop back up in
weird places but obviously they don't
have any plans to do a Howard the Duck
movie or even a TV show for that matter
there's the big revelation about Stan
Lee's cameos he plays the same character
in all of at least his Marvel Cinematic
Universe cameos you could stretch that
to the other Marvel Foxx films the Sony
spider-man films if you want because
technically Sony has a sharing
arrangement but it's just a way of
canonizing Stan Lee in a much bigger way
instead of turning it into like a
one-off cameo in each of these movies
he's a much bigger part of the Marvel
Universe and obviously the watchers very
big Marvel comic book race didn't ever
know if they'd be able to do them in the
movies Kevin Feige clarified that there
is a sharing arrangement when it comes
to big cosmic races so Fox has a very
specific list of characters Marvel has
theirs but when it comes to big races
they get to share them in the Kree as
part of that too so that means that
Marvel could totally do a version of the
kree-skrull war in a future cosmic movie
if they wanted to
even more Thor Ragnarok there's a Cronin
cameo when they're making all those
jumps they jump through a planet and you
see Cronin bashing another member of his
race on a lone planet the actual legit
Cronin character will show up in Thor
Ragnarok played by Ty Cobb OTT he sort
of the warm-up match before he gets to
the Incredible Hulk and this big trailer
scene they brought back the ask of
aerion joke from the first film Peter
quill says that they pulled a big bank
job he laid with and asked of Aryan the
that they used to help kill ego is
actually a piece of construction
equipment they say that yondu used to do
a bank job in ask of area all kinds of
ego the Living Planet Easter eggs so in
the comics he was born in the black
galaxy which was created by the
Celestials ego says that he is a
celestial just a slightly different
twist in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but the Celestials were created by the
dark Celestials which were created by
the first firmament the first version of
the first universe ever in the Marvel
Universe so is like the very first thing
to ever exist
gated servants called ends the dark
Celestials those servants made their own
servants called NZ Celestials in and so
on and so forth so that's where
characters like Esau and the searcher
come from those big cosmic beings they
are very few of them now we know if
there's ego there's probably other
Celestials floating around alive in the
universe somewhere so hopefully they'll
pop up in interesting ways in the other
cosmic movies that Marvel does but we
pretty much get to see every iteration
of ego in the comics so he looks like
this in the more recent comics but
there's been different versions like he
appears as a face here he can make a
human body for himself so different
artists different writers have used the
character in different ways but he
showed up a lot during Thor comics the
first time he ever showed up in a comic
book was when Thor was hired to get rid
of him
but the way he spreads himself through
other planets the way he takes over
other bodies it works a little bit
differently but he can plant himself in
another planet and then grow and take
that over but if he gets hurt he gets
like giant chunks blown out of him by
other big space creatures like Galactus
tries to kill him a couple times in the
comics he can regain his mass by eating
other planets Peter quill talks about
eternity this is a big Easter Egg a lot
of people are like oh my god did he
actually say that so yes eternity in the
comic books is the representation of
everything that exists the entire
multiverse itself during the big
sequence where ego starts activating all
the spores on the other planets James
Gunn's parents show up the actor that
plays Peter Quill's grandfather shows up
again they even bring back young Peter
quill for the sequence when you see him
laying in the field listening to music
with his mother and probably one of the
funniest Easter eggs was David
Hasselhoff czar do hassle proud that
person you told me about the ones that
owned the boat no it was a talking car
that helped him fight crime cut to them
actually bringing David Hasselhoff in
present-day into the movie when ego is
shifting forms I try to give you what
you want Peter so if you guys spotted
any other Easter eggs that I didn't
include in the video just write them
below in the comments I'm sure if we
watched the movie ten more times we'll
find a whole bunch more stuff James Gunn
said that a big sequence of the film
that served as a huge easter egg got cut
out early in the development phase
maybe he'll reveal what that is when he
does the commentary for the movie but
what's going to happen next
is a whole bunch of flash tonight but
leave all your requests for Marvel
videos in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner david juarez please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for that next video you can
click here for brand new defenders and
you can click here for all my Guardians
clothes credit fees thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight